whoa
yo mama
[Applause]
[Music]
pizza is the food of the people but what
happens when you take one of the world's
most accessible dishes and ice it out
with caviar truffle platinum and gold
today is all about expensive pizza the
ultra luxe high-end pies i could only
dream of creating when i first got into
the pizza game my challenger today is
nicole and idi from mythical kitchen
nicole is the host of the new series
meetcute and on the show fancy fast food
she's all about taking everyday dishes
and tricking them out with the most
insane ingredients there's only one
person i want as our judge bronx rapper
dream doll dream doll knows the keys to
a real new york slice and can also ball
out with the best of them anyone can
throw a bunch of money at a pizza and
make it look fancy but can nicole and i
cook up an expensive slice that's
actually worth the price tag let's find
out
[Music]
nicole welcome to peace awards i'm so
excited and we're so excited to have you
here yeah i love the dance do the dance
again
it's from the inside and it comes out
you know i'm from new york the home of
the dollar slice yes people have an
expectation that pizza is supposed to be
cheap but do you think there's a time to
really just like ball out on pizza i
think there's always a time and place to
ball out we have a great show called
fancy fast food where we take like
regular smegular burgers and you know
throw truffles and wag you at it so this
is kind of familiar territory for me but
i've never done it with a pizza like
this first things first let's talk about
this dough yeah so i made a beautiful
iranian saffron dough so as you can see
it has these beautiful saffron threads
through it oh it looks good let's see
that so we're going to take some
beautiful compte cheese and we're just
going to sprinkle that all around a lot
of people don't like a lot of cheese on
pizza but i don't care no no [ __ ] it up
[ __ ] me up when people are like that's
too much cheese the limit does not exist
i don't know about you and then i'm
gonna put some gorgeous truffle cheese
as well i'm trying to do a fancy
schmancy this is the place for fancy
schmancy you're right and then this is
my secret ingredient these are
chanterelle mushrooms cooked down with
some dom so i got some spec spec is like
prosciutto sexy cousin you know what i
mean
she went to harvard
just gonna finish off with just a
sprinkle of salt and then i'm just gonna
hit it with a little bit of pepper too
okay and then after this once it bakes
then it's gonna get really fancy okay
we're gonna get rich up in here
bye
so long see you later
wow
so this is my beautiful oily pizza we're
gonna take some gorgeous truffle burrata
here
look it's like a little john music video
you see that yes so we're just going to
open this up we're going to splay it out
like so put some crust pistachios and
then
a little bit of caviar straight in the
center and now the piece of resistance
some black truffle i got to clap it up
for you let's do a little bit of black i
love black truffle okay i'm done with my
pizza there you go that is the bianca oh
no i have one more part okay i have gold
leaf all right because i'm a real rich
man
right
on the top wow i feel like an artist now
that looks expensive
there you go i'm done
this is the bianca deodo pizza okay let
me get a slice okay yes ma'am all right
so my whole point with this pizza was to
be not as assertive as other people are
with expensive stuff you know people put
a bunch of random [ __ ] on pizza i'm not
here to do that i'm here to make a
delicious pizza that our guests judge
will absolutely adore and love to eat
again and again and spend that money
because they're spending it well right
this is an investment pizza and it's so
important to give people when they spend
all that money give them something they
can truly enjoy oh my gosh this is the
best day ever two nicoles in the kitchen
cooking expensive pizzas throwing
truffles and caviar and money at
everything
this is what life's about
i can't wait for your pizza
all right nicole so are you ready for
what i've got today i was born ready i
can tell you what i can't wait to see
what you got well it's so crazy because
this was just like this mad dream i had
as you can tell i love black and
platinum but i was like you know what i
want to introduce the internet to some
edible platinum wow so what i did was i
did a squid ink dough and you see the
consistency is so silky the color is
impeccable so i'm gonna do like slices
of smoked provolone on the base gorgeous
what kind of cheese is this this is
grande mozzarella so we're gonna be
pretty cheesy yeah and just because it's
a white pie i'm just gonna add garlic
oil to give it a little
you know juice up in there fantastic i
like how our pizzas are similar but very
different yes they're like sisters i'm
gonna cook this just like this and then
when i finish i'm gonna top it and add
everything else that's here all right
and i'm gonna launch this baby
oh my god she's gorgeous yes
it is beautiful nicole
okay so now we're gonna put a little bit
of the edible platinum flakes all over
the crust
i love how this is so light and it just
flies everywhere like fairy dust this
pizza is extra so now we have some
expensive ass
wagyu
and we topped it also with the platinum
fantastic so let's just get this all on
here this is an iced out pizza then
we're gonna add some black truffles to
that so what i did was i cooked the
truffles a little bit because it gives
it like a nice little flavor
and now i have these blue
beautiful potato chips with the roe on
it oh my god i'm obsessed with it so
that's the that's the surf and turf of
it all and then i have some little micro
greens to go in between and then the
last thing there's more there can't be
more one more thing is we're gonna get
some good old
fancy ass
caviar oh my gosh this is ridiculous
like no for real this is expensive oh my
god my price went up
yesterday's price is not today's price
i've never wanted to dig in more please
cut it there we go
it's complex it's balanced it's salty
it's savory it has crunch it has soft it
has chew it has everything you want in a
pizza you killed it look at you nicole
you were the perfect contestant for this
show can i give her a hug to give you i
couldn't even feel better this was an
incredible experience and you know let's
go to the judge's table and see what
they think let's do it we've got dream
doll here she's a new york girl she's a
rapper she's a rich girl we nailed it
two nicoles two expensive pizzas one
dream doll
let's go let's go
[Music]
what's up y'alls dream doll and i'm
about to be eating some expensive pizza
okay i've had gold flake steak and i've
had gold flake chicken wings before but
i never had go flakes on my pizza oh
truffle truffle
gotta have your little truffle you tell
me oh
ciao this is cheesy baby yo mama with
water
[Applause]
wow
this is so good
i'm going to try to copy off this is
stephanie rich [ __ ] pizza okay
caviar tastes like sardines a little bit
now the quest is question crust is so
good it just tastes so buttery
yo truffle is mad nasty truffle butter
don't taste like this when i try truffle
by myself i don't like it but when the
pizza it compliments so perfectly oh one
thing i would say though
is very greasy i still eat it with the
grease but you feel me if i could say
one thing
i'll say that
[Music]
this is really a babbage pizza though
because you see the wagoo the caviar
like you found me definitely suffering
turf with a little bop in it you know
i'll probably sell you this place for
like 500.
yeah i got something going right there i
love the the squid ink dough though i
thought i wasn't gonna like it was a
little scary and when i read it i'm like
think about the octopus
[Music]
i gotta get knocked off i'm sorry the
balls from the caviar popping in my
mouth it's just too much textures in my
mouth but the bread
fire the wagyu
fire flakes fire this is a bad [ __ ]
pizza i told you that like this is a bad
[ __ ] of the pizzas but
as far as the taste
i'll put this bread on that piece of
bomb
these were great pieces it's going to be
tough for me to choose this one right
here because one got this and the other
one got that you know but overall this
is both some designer pizzas these are
some bougie pieces and i'm gonna be hard
for me to pick one
[Applause]
[Music]
dream doll thank you so much for being
here thank you we're so excited to have
you here
to eat for me i'm glad to be here dream
doll we're here for a reason we made
expensive luxe pizzas nicole and i had a
ball we really did but
the final verdict is on you overall both
pieces are super beautiful they're very
unique which is my middle name
you know so i'm not really the nuts girl
like i'm not really a pistachio like a
cashew eater but it worked it worked
what i did say was when i got towards
the crust it bothered me a little bit
the caveat didn't bother me
until i got hair
and it was like knockout season for the
caviar you told me it was like popping
in my mouth and i couldn't really get
into it but i love the bread on this oh
my god i wish i would have made me some
garlic nuts with some tomato sauce
next time
but um
[Music]
i'm gonna have to go with this pizza
[Applause]
this was a tough one but i couldn't do
it with anyone better oh nicole you
really did it for mythical chef just
bringing home the clown yeah so i know
he'll be proud of you thank you thank
you so much for being on the show my
pleasure thank you for having me it was
an honor to cook in your kitchen and we
can have a rematch any time come to l.a
let's do it shake on chicken on it
you're going to check some garlic
[Applause]
[Music]
you